and we are live with Casey nonduality
hello Atlas what's up what's going on
brother what's going on man what's going
on my white brother my white
Brother The Goonies are together in
person we are in Austin Texas live from
Austin Texas the second iners interview
down here your first hangout with
someone in the non-duality community in
person true which is cool too I've had a
couple of the inperson non-d DU Hangouts
you have you've had so many yeah they
they can get a bit uh non- dual Master
bit of as know yeah yeah I yeah it does
kind of turn into that online turns into
that online too though yeah yeah it does
man it it just seems to yeah it's just
how humans kind of go I guess it's just
like masturbating about group group
things that resonate in the
group like in its own
style yeah yeah and like I well humans
masturbate to all kinds of things I'm
discovering it's crazy you seen those
crazy categories on there's no control
of anything on porn sites and whatnot
the categories yeah the categories
sometimes I I just uh watch like PornHub
as YouTube like I'll just browse the
categories like without even touching
myself I'll just browse it and be like
dude this is crazy [__] like there's
lots of crazy categories on right right
some stuff is kind of like shocking and
so you can't even touch yourself because
it's just like whoa I need
to you know I just I'm not I need to
like prepare myself into different way
you know to even accept this because
this is so
weird with like a butt plug like that's
how to
accept I wanted to get one of those cool
looking butt plugs that that are like um
all full featured and have like the
streamers use them use them to make
money and and things on the streaming so
I hear I I absolutely don't know I have
no experience what if we did a wild
reveal to the audience right now that we
were both you sitting on butt
plugs well we were going to save this
for the end of the podcast but today's
sponsor yeah is this butt plug
company wholeness wholeness
that oh my God we have a brand of butt
plug company it's called wholeness
holess get
it [__] I have the Shivers this is a
real product this is going to happen
yeah all right we'll talk we'll talk
business later a whole um Suite of of
different styles of of anal uh play
um one second I got a little cut out
with the guest cam let's see if it comes
back here in a
moment okay it is back that's nice let
me H get a quick adjust on
her
guess I got to turn on
her Zoom let's bring her up to
1.4 and then we'll turn on her
tracking all right and we are back nice
that was pretty quick all right watch
out it might have been like it might
have been like oh my [__] a bumping of
one of the cords or something oh it
actually just just the vibrations see if
one sec let me turn let me turn our
track let's turn our tracking off one
second let me do this first turn the
guest off and then mine off and then
let's uh just push it if we can just try
to push
it yeah at least for now try that can we
see if this will work for a sec let's
try that try to can you can you just
yeah yeah and then can you try to leave
it in that position right
there
no I think it's slipping because of the
surface okay give us one second fam
we're going to briefly adjust the mic
arm one sec fam actually let me switch
to the to the uh table cam yeah here we
go this is real
life
unfortunately okay two three all right
now it's now it's pressed up against it
now let's close her up yeah that looks
really
good close
up as'll go okay okay okay
try to not give her too much uh
stress easy yeah that should be fine
that's great yeah just so come up now
come up to
her okay all right so let's go back to
the split shot now we can turn tracking
back on let's do that
quick mine's on and yours is on
beautiful yeah yeah okay now we're back
all right so speaking of our um our
suite of uh wholeness of our company our
our anal company called wholeness so
okay so we're going to have um butt
plugs is one of the uh one of the two
toys we're going to manufacture Flagship
product Flagship product probably is
going to be a butt plug it it will be
yeah now
but okay so I want
probably um VI I want vibratory
capacities and whatnot and that and also
the maybe that like motion motion
capacity in that one the vibratory
motion so these are like the flagship
little circular motion thing circular
motion maybe it can do a small insertion
but if it's getting like a huge
insertion I probably couldn't stream
while being
hugely here's the thing is like it
doesn't matter what what you want
sometimes it just depends so if you're
getting it for you it matters what you
want but um this thing people can make
money with this thing they can hook it
up to their live streams other people
can choose what to do to them for money
and it's a great way to earn money in
this day and this time period we're in
right now I think so and I say we just
pop in uh the latest AI of course we'll
have
gp4 turbo enabled the butt plug in the
butt plug whates what does gp4 in the
butt plug do though like what would it
so if we think about it it's really just
this piece of Machinery that you shove
in your butthole right and it has a
whole bunch of features and it reminds
me of a smartphone right you have
sensors and features and then people
make apps and so we'll we'll just make
butt plug apps or like butt like butt
apps butt apps a butt store but what a
butt store but then okay like what
people can use features vibration
vibration yes so give me the sample apps
or features cuz I can only think of
vibration like swirling
inserting um so yeah yeah we got those
uh people love music I hear oh the buff
plug plays music so what you do is you
you can easily do Bluetooth I've
actually programmed Bluetooth chips so I
can I can program a Bluetooth chip in
there um and you can hook it up to your
phone and whatever you're playing
whatever the beat is you can you can be
feeling feeling the
beat yeah right many different ways it
can be shocking you we can put a little
shock thing in there interesting okay so
then are are the are the speakers like
um like inside of the butt plug
or are are they kind are they kind of
pushing the sound waves up into the anal
cavity itself yeah should do that and
then like the and then the electrical
like you said the rhythmic like you can
feel the music with the like little
electric shocks every once in a while to
have you ever have you ever done the
radio where you bite a stick and you can
hear the radio
play
is it like tuned into a certain
frequency no it's like a science
experiment it's a science experiment you
can get headphones basically take the
headphones apart and you got the two
chords and you you basically connect
them together but you extend it out with
copper cable and you just wrap around a
stick and you put it in your mouth and I
think we had it I think it's just a
wooden stick or a pencil back in school
and you put it in your mouth and the
electromagnetism you can your teeth uh
the vibrations go through your bone in
your teeth and into your ear canal and
you can hear the radio while you're
biting the stick oh interesting so you
you become an antenna yeah you become
you become a speaker it uses your bone
structure as speaker system instead of
the audio instead of the Audio Waves
going through the air yeah and then it's
just the vibrations going through your
bone your bones yeah same concept
conducer yeah and then the and then you
hear
it
yeah what are our other butthole um
because we have our Flagship product and
it has all of its
apps yeah yeah so pump and bump is the
first St that's like the music one right
oh pump and bump it'll as as you bump
it'll
pump I love the name okay God wholeness
dude what a great a s of anal
products okay so
then um now Hess is definitely not not
just in today's episode we discovered
that wholeness is not just non-duality
and nature of reality it's also a a it's
also our anal product line our company
of anal products so now yes today's
episode is sponsored to you by wholeness
Hess oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay what are our other how it goes what
are our other products besides the
flagship
one maybe um
beads beads so like anal beads anal
beads yeah what about like Rings like a
ring that you can kind of like put
around your rim of your butthole
but that doesn't necessarily insert but
that like vibrates and can uh kind of
like give you some like can be
controlled by like voice or app or
whatever where you yeah yeah how do we
how does it how do we stick it and make
it stay right that's the
thing put a little attachment that goes
like up your B hole and then just a very
small attachment into the butthole but
that's like a butt plug but oh my poor
mic oh the poor mic yeah grab her you
know all right we're you know what you
at least for now you want to just hold
it like that yeah okay is this good yeah
at least for now and then I can and come
and fix it is that going to bother you
though this is Satan's Fault by the way
yeah blame mess everything up blame it
all on
sight Dirty
Bastard well you let me know and I can
I'll come over there when that gets
tiring yeah um this is great actually
I'm just getting so irritated by that uh
I'm enjoying this this is nice okay
you're GNA hold it for a bit yeah yeah
I'm just GNA hold it here it's just not
going to stay up otherwise yeah yeah
darn it
Lucifer C
you power through this I'm sorry for the
the Christian references they may pop up
it doesn't
matter nothing does turn off the guest
nothing does matter yeah I'm going to
come I don't want that to be super
annoying for rest time so I was thinking
also um if there's like books you can
put under it right here or something oh
interesting it's because the weight of
this is just is just making it well and
because this and this isn't gri it's
supposed to be gri way more it would
have never happened if this wasn't grip
like this so it's primarily because of
the gripping yeah yeah so let's uh I'll
grab a little thing like you said also
to double down on on it so now hold it
I'll gra something under
it let's go with
this hey I was thinking that
yeah that that'll do it there we
go now uh better than nothing now let me
I'll tighten her
now
[Music]
okay
now perfect well done sir
hallelujah
hallu hallelujah hallelujah
hallelujah getting in that Christmas
spirit okay we are we are back with the
tracking let's let's put the split up
there it is all
right okay cool cool back to bus back to
business and we'll take care of that
later but now we don't have to touch it
for the rest of the show which is great
yeah yeah yeah yeah so much better so
just briefly um Casey's got uh a channel
on nonduality you can go and check it
out here um the link will be in the bio
below we'll also have his website link
in there as well for you to check out
and also uh Instagram or what Instagram
um still working on that to get to get
the official one up but for now the
website and and the YouTube channel
YouTube channel he's got a bunch of fun
content on the YouTube channel you can
see there we have Whispers And the void
a Moonlight chat radical
nonduality thoughts on thoughts on
thoughts there are no thoughts truly
nobody Zoom Etc so
okay all kinds of all kinds of stuff
nothing lots of literally
nothing one of the worst YouTube
channels you've ever seen as you know
you can't get anything from it fam yes
yes so let's let's throw the split back
on now okay
so so we have our um company called
wholeness now which is great we have um
the flag products we plug Flagship anal
plug Y and then we have and we have the
beads anal beads anal beads which we can
still describe more and then we have
never tried those but I small vibrating
thing that can go up right that La that
third one we were talking about I I one
time accidentally got one lost in my
anal cavity a ring or a no it's it was
meant for women and it was like a little
pill oh yeah yeah and I'm
like yeah I can do this but did you but
I couldn't do it you shout it out though
I yeah I had a figure it out quick
because it was still on on and it was
warming up and you couldn't dig it out
no it it it's small so it was just
like yeah but this is and all small
though this is
small depends on how [__] big your
anus is your
anal I don't know man you'd have to tell
me but yeah we'll we'll take a look
later I can't see very well back there
oh yeah wholeness the most Clear Channel
of non-duality
yet you know it's funny it's like the
conversations they always go south and
so what I enjoy about this is that we
just embraced the South we just start by
going down
south you know straight to the anus with
the they always go sou this this is
non-duality right radical
nity they always go south meaning they
always go to
sex no no oh oh they always go to uh
goony uh nonsense yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay but sex for me is a huge part of
goon nonsense it's like a big category
of goony nonsense it's like all that
matters apparently these days I mean the
whole thing
the whole thing I mean the most the most
uh OG program within uh that empty
Indescribable space is biology and
reproduction so that's why it's so yeah
it's incredible this Infinity's got to
go on
apparently yeah there's so much untapped
unexplored I don't know what to call it
like space yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's so endless that the sexual
force is this main
infinity or whatever you want to
say there's so much to explore I
remember in the story there's like um in
ancient Egypt there was there's like 19
Sexes they had like different kinds of
sexuality
orientations this was some some kind of
like dialogue from Drunvalo mzc I think
and it was so interesting um because
they we were talking about like Sexual
Energy
channels and how most people think
there's just kind of like one or
something where like the
Kundalini is also like the main Channel
but he was saying no there's like
there's like six different channels and
only at some point in time um have all
of them been like activated at
once and uh and the end result was in
ancient Egypt you can do the ceremony
with masculine and feminine energy you
have some kind of special energy sex and
create uh essentially like anything you
want it it's funny how the stories kind
of
get Bland at that point it's like and
then yeah ultimate Cosmic powers or or
like and then
you all of these distinctions are way
too uh I mean they're just cutting up
the air or the ocean into random pieces
I
mean what's the difference between they
being six energy channels or 19 or how
seven chakras or 14 or or like you know
how some people even like divide the
body and the mind and then they get
obsessed about it and then they're like
this is this is body and this is mind
and this is and it's like dude I can't
even tell you what the difference is
between Sensations and thoughts I can't
because the moment that I start saying
what it is you're already turning
Infinity into ideas and you
can't
precisely and so that's sort of this one
of the funnest Parts about nonduality is
the unspe the unspeakability
yeah it's like the ceasing of the
mechanism that is obsessive compulsive
always wanting to break everything down
into
stuff X object y
object objectification and judgment and
all kinds of [__] and it's weird though
it's because there's nothing wrong with
that in fact it gets more
beautiful maybe in the story at least
here like the com the obsessive compul
there's plenty of that in the story here
can get more beautiful and more more
intense actually actually like it kind
of for a bit uh the OCD that I had would
kind of it went away but it would like
flare up and just be like what just so
wild and and it's like whoa just kind of
watching it it felt kind of like sitting
back um sometimes other times there's no
concept of that because you're
unconscious right you are the OCD just
fully in the experience whatever it is
whatever it is and there's no bound
between an OCD experience or this
experience or a virtual experience or a
sexual experience I mean you know we can
talk about the differences but
um right I mean what you just said a
second ago was that there's no matter
right so what you just said a second ago
is so powerful cuz it's like if if one
hasn't in a way uncovered what is
underlying
everything which
this unspeakable that is underlying it
all light energy whatever the [__] you
want to
say that that
informs whatever is appearing so by
uncovering the
underlying substance or whatever it g it
informs whatever is the sensation or
thought or experience or whatever is
actually apparently happening and
without uncovering that what under lies
it then the world of separation is so
[__] solid and the world of lack and
the world of being a solid real entity
in time and it just is it annihilates
one into like the most contractive box
imaginable and so that's what the whole
the whole process of going back into
what can't be left and then you still
have to collapse The Duality back into
your own [__] character there's
nowhere else to go
and there's no one to do it
[Music]
to you know um man I can't tell you
almost everything like almost everything
I say I'm going to do and then what I
actually do ends up not
aligning and it's just like it just like
oh wow like I really don't have much
control over my life do I there just
different little things like that and
one of them is like if there's no matter
at all it see it so what the [__] it
really seems like there's matter there's
so much
evidence there's people you can talk to
about this forever and ever and ever and
ever science people to reaffirm yeah
certainly there's there doesn't matter
you know but um yeah it's just like one
of those weird vivid dreams at night or
kind of like uh maybe a psychedelic
where yeah just seems so
real and there's no comparison so you're
not going to know when it's not it it's
always it tada T you can't get away from
the [__] [__] not even there good
luck it's pretty [__] up for but it's
also so pure and simple just this so
whatever is appearing right now
yeah
yeah I love the
vividness the Indescribable and
indistinguishability there's no
boundaries you know yeah you got like
eyeballs but that's a
concept
yeah and
so so then it's just unknown what the
[__] you know you could say like I'm
looking at
you or you could say no no I'm not I'm
not looking at you doesn't matter what
you think you're saying yeah she just
coming out empty sound holy [__] though
full also it's so different than
what in the story apparent people think
non radical nonu radical nity is it's
different it's it's not even just like a
seek seeking energy killer it's it's
weird like sometimes when I'm talking to
people just into this there's no people
by the way this is all story of course
but it kind of breaks that barrier of
like reality a little bit because all
reality is anyways is pretty
thin barrier not barrier thin a thin
pile of Concepts that right built up
since something birth there's no birth
something TI to that yeah just it's
about damn time I feel like in the story
things are breaking down like like
this yeah that's what I love about this
message that is just um even if you
think you know what you're talking about
which sometimes that arises and it's you
know at the end of at the end of the day
it doesn't matter yeah it's
perfect you're perfect Atlas I know
that's the beauty you're perfect you've
never made a wrong choice you never made
a right
choice and you've never even made a
what's a choice man
mhm well I mean you've made choices I
guess you could say that
maybe the Perfection is a little bit oh
[__] see there's no control man I told
you I wouldn't touch this you have you
noticed have you have you noticed how uh
handcuffed me noticed the the Perfection
is something that is so quickly moved
away
from you can't move away from it it's
noticed yeah but you can yeah but it
it's really that that
stilling
to that mystery that mhm and then like
the intensity that that is moved away
from
basically because it's it's without
ground and without box and without idea
and all this kind of stuff yeah yeah
yeah yeah and then at the same time it's
like that is not a ground either and so
get your [__] mask back on get your
character game back on and and get the
[__] back into this dream simulation who
this no who but who's going to do those
things no not not that anyone does it
right right not that not not that
someone you just said you so get back
it's almost like you were like like I
hate that like what is it what what's
being suggested is that it's not that
there's someone that's what not that
there's someone that's doing it it's
that there's no other real way to
language it because there's still the
character there's still the dream
simulation whatever you want to call
this appearance and to to try to say
that the still Perfection
mystery that that is another ground
right is actually not uhhuh so therefore
get your ass back into the war zone
[__] oh yeah it's logical yeah yeah
yeah therefore and what is the war zone
the war zone is this whatever's
appearing yeah okay it's the simulation
it's whatever it is now within that what
is what's the case is it decentralized
basic needs and love and abundance for
all in a unified Earth of light cities
and people living in those waking up
every day free or is it you know
centralized nation states with massive
propaganda machinery and Division and
separation and
centralized uh
currencies monitoring every move and War
happening across these nation states and
all kinds of of [__] all kinds of
[__] so so one has to still put the
character not that someone's doing it
but once Cela put the character and the
dream simulation back into motion
there's no ground which is oh I'm going
to be totally nothing and totally still
and totally perfect beyond all bounds
and all ideas it's not a ground
[__] that's not even um um you
know the more I think about spirituality
and my whole life time of it it's like
what was the thing I was trying to
get what already is all I know what art
is right but like art so at the end of
the the chase at the end of the chase
there was this Flow State that when I
was in this Flow State it was
like I was just one with all that is and
it was like so beautiful because I
wasn't there I was out of the way and
and because of that you can kind of get
out of the way and like Channel other
entities and these clear messages can
come through seemingly they're like
where did that come from
so um that felt like this is what I was
this is what I was missing kind of my
whole life was this Flow State and when
you're in the flow state if you can just
stay in that flow State all the
time but God the maintenance there's a
lot of Maintenance to it it was a lot of
fun though and so it was really sad
finding out it's not that it's not that
I found out yeah it's not the right way
to put it but it was sad to have that
fall away it it did the channeling stuff
like I I've tried it but it's almost
like um you know it's all story maybe
it's real but it feels more like
now the Storyteller is awake to himself
reading a story book that he didn't know
he was reading previously it's just is
the you know how creative our brains can
be when they're in different states
absolutely how consistent they can be
and you know different hypnotic States
and yep I love that huge hugely
engrossed in it constantly yeah yeah
constantly it's actually it it becomes
more and more impossible to leave that
basically M like the whole thing becomes
one constant hypnosis one constant Flow
State and it's never ending cuz the
whole thing is hypnosis the whole thing
like this conversation is hypnosis
itself basically yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then the audience that's
watching it is also in hypnosis right
now listen you know and so then then the
whole thing is okay if this is the
Perfection that is Flowing which is
impossible to say what it is then every
single word that's coming doesn't have a
doer but yet at the same time every
single word is Hypnotic and it has an
effect on the appearance apparently and
so therefore therefore if the words that
are said are are that yeah just you know
hang back and get [__] by Daddy and
Mommy government across the world you
know just sit back and allow um the
[__] in in the anus of all of The
Selfish greedy corrupt Nar style mother
stuff there's some energy behind this
yeah no it is it really is it is an aner
it really is it's got to be
unrepressed it's extremely repressed at
least in the appearance it's extremely
repressed and so that Energy's got to
come for and it's got to [__] say
like for example you know I'll come I'll
come pull it up right here on on screen
but it's got to say
that you know that like solar Punk is
just one of the genres of what the
future of Earth can look like I love
this I love this yeah yeah yeah I was
into this kind of thing with the ET in
the storyline and I still am man I think
it's a beautiful idea well well because
here's the thing have an earth that's
sustainable you know self- sustainable
and there's there's truly nothing else
to do that that's this is the thing it's
no one to do it but there's nothing else
to do so what do we do is this there's
nothing else to do but this this is
what's being what's being shared through
this hypnosis is that all
good minute 15 minute warning out but
that's but you still have more because I
do I do I forgot to reset the alarm
thank you for that yeah yeah cool so
basically there's there's nothing else
but building new Earth that's left shut
up that's my that's my favorite movie
man which one lapia to Castles in the
Sky it's that solar Punk one he's got
the um yeah yeah yeah little Castle in
the Sky it's one of yaki's movies a good
stuff nice always love that
concept yeah yeah story there's stories
of extraterrestrial something or another
where they had they had this planet
version of Earth it's a story of a
parallel version of Earth where there
was this AI essentially mini planet that
orbited Earth and used AI to just
maintain the Earth how would have done
originally you know it's funny like it's
just going back
to if humans or whatever it's all story
we're going in the story humans didn't
evolve so much like we did or whatever
however worked want to [__] the Earth up
so hard well and it so right here's the
thing you don't we don't have to get
into lots of like meaning and purpose we
don't have to get into that but it is
possible that one of the quote story
arcs of what's apparently happening is
that is that Earth had to go into such
insane separation and War and all kinds
of [__] in order for it to know or
experience or see what is possible with
this kind of a future so now um there
was some comments in the live chat that
I just want to address it was about um
some of the people that have been
watching the channel were um were
wondering like about the channel coming
back like this strongly and they're
excited about it and and I was just
replying back that much love it's never
been gone because I spent those two
years kind of internationally traveling
and stuff like that and I was barely uh
trickling out videos while I was doing
that but now the Channel's come back
super super strongly with stuff like
this basically with a very um uh like
it's there so much excitement about
non-duality so much and there's also so
much excitement about building from
wholeness
for all these next Generations
apparently to come through into this
playground Earth that are totally free
cuz dude when we were kids just go back
to it when we were kids when we were
five or 10 or whatever as long as you
had the basic needs met like with your
parents and stuff you had your shelter
and you had your food and water and
stuff and energy and whatnot what were
you doing every day like in the summer
for example when there wasn't any school
you were waking up every day and you
were just
playing yes that was it yes and that's
that's still alive that energy and it
was just
like and it's back now it's back now
because you know when you were a kid you
had it right all that matters is
whatever matters in the moment you know
and usually fun is What mattered and
usually yeah scheming to get like as
many cookies from the cookie jar as
possible without Grandma finding out
because you love Grandma like you
[__] love cookies and like you're
smart if you're one of those smart I was
I thought I was smart we got a lot of
trouble and
stuff and it was so much fun now looking
yeah
back and there's nothing wrong with
looking back it's just
and yeah kind of when the falling away
happens at first it can be kind of
disassociating but it just settles back
into how it was of like yeah sure I I we
we can go back into any story I'm not
like a zombie
robot how you just I love how you just
said a second ago it's just this that
you that you got that you can feel sort
of the what was never lost of that
childlike fun and spontaneity and flow
and you can feel more of that coming
alive now and that more that that
manifest that manifest is like this
because the basic needs are met and
everything else just takes care of
itself that's the dream yes
yes I'm such a huge fan of this dream
shut up I'm immediately on board I just
put the pieces together what this is
because there this is what's being said
is that there's just nothing wasting so
much time just surviving with the basic
needs we have technology to do this [__]
man AI is going to be huge part of
this then we can spend all day just
living out the creativity and yeah sure
you be like well creativity in the slave
labor and when we're after to do 9o5 get
creative [__] like I do I whip
my dick
out yeah so you know but I'd rather
build like cyber cities like I love
engineering so yeah but I'm forced to
work at McDonald's cuz I was I was fired
ra right that's that's the thing and I
don't want to find another job dang it
but apparently I
am so that that's the thing is happening
dude I am actually those basic those
basic needs being met oh yeah is freedom
yeah and freedom to play to do to
whatever appears arises music Joy heart
whatever your heart wants but there's it
also isn't that it's kind of is that
kind of like the Eden concept a little
bit or is that going into spirituality
too much
probably one way to call it is Paradise
or Eden or heaven or whatever or for or
for the Earth or New Earth or whatever
there's endless conceptual ways to
describe what it is yeah screw all that
[__] the's start fresh but the thing the
one the the the thing that the thing
that shifts in a way that apparently
shifts is that one no
longer um even considers the possibility
that that's not going to
happen so basically what another way to
say it is it's it becomes constituted
it's like a frequency that becomes
constituted as the body itself like the
body becomes yeah yeah it's like first
I'm getting energetic downloads let's go
let's go let's go let's go let's
go I got real Shivers on that let's go
so oh
that's the that's the thing okay all you
egoic [__] out there I feel you
we think we're all
that but this [__] this conversation is
happening just as like naturally flowing
as like the cells in our body
communicating and maybe there's some
like ignorant [__] cells are
like like viruses are so cool because
they go into cells and like right over
their
bodies not that I want to do that but um
any in a way there there is an analogy
for that here too so for example you can
say there's there's this there's this
there's this empty empty impossible to
describe space and then there's all of
these kinds of programs that run from
that space now the one of the most
common programs that's running is
separation okay it's it's that I I am a
separate self and a separate entity and
I lack and I'm in a world of separate
entities and I must take advantage of
them and bomb Other Nation States and
all kinds of [__] like that now if you
go back a little further back back back
a little further to where everything
sort of arising out of you can you can
sort of see that the nature of that
program is just a contraction it it
itself is just a contraction it's an
assumption it's a belief it's all kinds
of stuff that can actually be uh
expanded and liberated
anded of and then what what it's it's
actually fascinating that you said virus
because kind of what what happens is
that this hypnosis and we talked about
hypnosis earlier the words themselves
are can kind of be like a virus that is
coming
into the contracted area let's call it
contracted area which is that uh I I
don't give a [__] about new Earth I
don't give a [__] about solar punk I
don't give a [__] about basic needs and
all of those things oh still good second
alarm yeah do you want to do you want to
check if there are other alarms and just
turn those off if there are other ones
yeah do that make sure and I'll make
sure we end on time okay cool now yeah
let's leave it up to you perfect but
keep talking I'm I'm I'm listening to
what you're saying and I can turn this
off so we don't lose the flow perfect so
okay so now imagine that these words
themselves um are the are like a
hypnosis that's coming through and that
the the
the the that the the the the like it's
like a viral possibility that they land
into that contracted uh Ness and that
they liberate that contracted from the
assumptions that the contracted is
apparently holding which is I am real I
am separate I lack all that kind of
programs and scripts now if that is
released or liberated what happens is
that there is a very deep like kind of
disidentification with the character
that can happen now if that
disidentification happens usually what
happens is the Timeless space of
wholeness that is literally nothing and
everything is finally recognized by that
then you can re-identify as the
character this is typically what happens
there's a reidentification with the
character cuz that that's not a ground
nothing being everything is not a ground
what is is not a ground nothing is a
ground so not even this these words are
a ground um what's being shared about
new Earth isn't a ground no ground but
yet at the same time when there is that
reidentification with the character
there's this like okay but now what like
now what now what yeah and that's where
New Earth and building basic needs
infrastructures and decentralizing
things and living abundantly like where
someone's waking up every day and they
can literally just play like the
innocent child however
however this yeah it's just that that's
the dream man
because there's so much potential like
come on so much to explore but we're
just hampered by these like caveman
things yeah so very exciting time to
live right now you know it is it's so
[__] exciting and I'm GNA I'm going
to say something that's a little bit uh
it can be a little cringe for um those
that don't that are dishonorable in a
way one way to put it is that dishonor
typically views this message as cringe
because what it wants is it wants for
itself so either it's very selfish and
it wants for itself only or it's selfish
in the sense that it's selfless and it's
and it's kind of abiding in a
nothingness that is actually this so you
can't actually abide in something that's
Transcendent than this because the
Transcendent thing is this so there's
another aspect of Dishonor which is
dishonoring the appearance by quote
relaxing in a space that transcends the
appearance because there is none there
is only the appearance so what is being
shared that is honor what is honor is
literally dying on the sword of new
Earth exhaust your body on building new
Earth there's nothing else to do my
friends or whatever else you or whatever
else appears your heart yeah yeah for
you it's new Earth for me it's now new
Earth because it already was now I just
know what it is right and isn't that
fascina I was just so irritated like why
do we have to work as a kid like I just
want I'm just building [__] with
batteries and it's so fun like R2D2's
and stuff you had it inside you and then
these words kind of hypnotically
activated what was already inside it was
already there it was already there this
is not something that's coming from a
central entity this is literally the
word of paradise itself it doesn't come
from a central place it's a non- central
place and it's just activating the the
program of paradise that was already
latently in there that was just
contracted by all kinds of other [__]
and that's the same thing for for
viewers and all kinds of [__] dude it's
already the the constituted ability
moving forward is really the the key you
just basically you don't budge from it I
know it can be annoying to people
sometimes but you don't budge from it
basically anytime that someone tries to
spew some sort of thing at you which is
selfishness or emptiness or some kind of
ground that wants to be spewed new Earth
isn't possible [__] go back to some job
or whatever what [__]
you yeah there's it's and it's it's not
even like like that it's just more like
yeah I understand and I I can understand
where you're coming from but this is
constituted as the new Earth much love
and then bye-bye you know it's just it's
just just that so or and dude do you
ever lose it sometimes oh i i l it all
the time
yeah you can try to like control and it
seems and you can improve yourself right
like you know we all know that we don't
need to say like self-improvement isn't
real but God whatever happens is just
really going to come out and and what
happen what may happen is that you're
tired of what's coming out and you may
want to improve yourself like I'm tired
of [__] with this microphone
and so I'm doing pretty good so far as
soon as we got it all stacked up here
but um yeah there's just a looseness
that comes when it's seen that that it's
all Happening by itself no matter and it
always has so whatever you
think
otherwise or
anything sure there's nothing wrong with
that one one one way to say this is that
the pro the program of self is sort of
in its own codes which kind of contract
it into a small narrative okay then then
what happens as you sort of are you you
sort of liberate those assumptions and
whatnot is that from this wholeness from
the spaciousness it is sort of like the
body just becomes an instrument for that
yeah apparently yeah and then the the
instrument itself it becomes obvious for
the instrument that there is nothing
else but Paradise is the only program
that's running and there's a question in
the chat about how do we build the new
the new Earth like what what are what
are we to how do we do that and whatnot
and just decentralizing basic needs
infrastructures homesteading
homesteading is a big one so like the
homed dow.com is the way that we're
doing it here so this is like tokens
that are literally backed by Food Forest
water wells 3D printed houses
communities solar energy wind turbines
batteries all that kind of stuff so
literally you go from fiat currency
that's not backed by anything in
centralized to then Bitcoins and
cryptocurrencies which are decentralized
but they're not backed by anything and
then you have home tokens and other dpin
networks decentralized physical
infrastructure networks which are
actually tokens backed by real world
perfect assets which is basic needs so
imagine within five or seven years or
something like that if you Homestead
with the Dow or if you just go out and
Homestead with friends or whatever it is
it doesn't matter how you do it just the
fact that you quote exit the old system
and you build the new system right exit
and build something that some of our
friends Rebecca and Jonathan Bush down
here are really passionate about as
they're phrasing for it and I love that
so much you exit and build you build the
new systems and then within 5 seven some
odd some years once those things become
self- sustaining on your property water
food energy and the space itself and
it's fully paid for and all that stuff
dude that's it because now yeah now you
have a self-sustaining home system and
at that point you can bring other people
that want to exit and build to that
acreage right oh wow yeah and so that's
how that's how the flywheel works yeah
oh that's exciting how so here I've
looked at the website a little bit how
how so if you have like assets if you
grow corn or something and you have cows
and you like make milk or something you
have milk right can you trade that in
for the
currency so here's you can buy the curen
so beautiful so here's here's the thing
I want to I want to make it clear cuz
there's basically an arc of of of like a
timeline Arc to this and the mechanism
itself end is beyond what you just
described so the end of it is beyond
money it's beyond barter it's beyond
nation states it's because everything's
it's it's because everything's on free
energy at that point everything Frey so
you can use things like massery equival
to things take things from Pure Energy
and bring them into into ma into matter
Sur just make it materialize materialize
and that kind of stuff so now so now
here's the thing I believe in that in
the story in some yeah in some um so in
the window as we get to that place where
the mechanism obsoletes itself cuz at
some point you're not going to need the
Dows you're not going to need them
everyone going living in abundant free
energy cities and to move and manifest
whatever they want and that kind of
create whatever they want yeah yeah in
Harmon in perfect harmony with Earth but
up until that point yes you can do
things like when you Homestead and you
have something that you love doing you
can do some sort of barter or exchange
on that Homestead or stuff like that
it's a process yeah it's an evolution
like anything it's an endless Evolution
never starts never ends apparently
always changing wow yeah I really love
the idea behind that so the con but the
concept it's it's all from um bringing
it back right to that freedom
that never has left you know and
seemingly now the freedom is still here
yeah it's just you may not feel it all
the time and I know everyone wants to
but let me just just stop okay you won't
you
won't
give it up like just give it up or you
don't have to but who would want to live
a life of just one sensation anyways I
think Steve Jobs I used to OCD level
like study Steve Jobs who like every
book on him and like read every quote
and I Tred to like become him so I took
acid and then I realized that was a lot
different than I thought it was going to
be but um he he did like meditation he
got way into meditation right did the
whole
Zen
um and it's a beautiful thing and then
he eventually he was just like you know
um but I don't want to just do this my
whole life like I want to go do other
stuff so he stopped didn't what he
wanted made iPhones that we have I don't
know where I was going with that but it
yeah it uh kind of like you're never
there's no Landing ever you think there
will be a landing okay so there's a
comment there's comments in here that
are loving our conversation about
homesteading and free energy and all
kinds of things like that which is
really fun and then there's also a
comment about how the thing that is most
liked is just [__] around taking
nothing seriously and playing a lot so
being as children 100% off grid all
kinds of stuff like that so that is the
frequency remember you were talking
about being like constituted like the
body becomes in a way constituted as
something that was never lost that was
never lost the child like innocent play
and freedom yeah just covered up or
suppressed maybe amongst other things so
it's like activating that
constitutionally and like that's that's
where the flow of the body goes and it
just it just Roars like actually a good
amount a good amount of the um okay
we're going to end in about 15 minutes
to give you a little bit of time to
prepare so perfect so one thing that's
been covered up or repressed a lot has
been sort of the the masculine Ro
dude yes and then that that Roar for New
Earth yes that is what is being
discussed you feel that that kind of
Roar for New Earth that kind of Ro for
new hell yeah the end it's energy man to
make
chessing that because that's that's been
super suppressed it has you can't it's
almost in the west it's like you can't
be yourself it's like someone someone's
basically someone's basically playing a
drum or like the the culture is kind of
playing a drum of suppress your
masculine Roar suppress your masculine
Roar suppress your masculine Roar don't
build new Earth don't build new Earth
suppress that masculine Roar don't build
new Earth be a selfish [__] be a selfish
[__] be a selfish [__] be a selfish [__]
repress your master ke in don't build
new Earth that's basically what's
happening is that how you want to live
your life that's basically one one thing
that's
happening Fu the wood drum baby the wood
drum baby yeah yeah can I of course come
on over
oh I watched your video probably five
times in a
row the wood drum baby you might want to
put it on this cuz then you don't have
to hold it and then it can vibrate
better yeah
yeah you got a good Tempo there I like
that yeah cuz I've done it enough times
yeah find it and beat it say whatever
you want freestyle the flow let it all
go say whatever you want walls
walls there walls everywhere there's
[__]
walls uh uh uh walls Let Them Fall build
new Earth yeah walls Let Them Fall Let
Them Fall build new Earth uh uh uh uh
walls Let Them Fall build new Earth you
hear the baby walls Let Them Fall build
new
Earth yeah yeah [__] I'm losing the
tempo I'm losing the tempo pick it up
pick it up a little pick it up a
little walls Let Them Fall build new
Earth uh walls Let Them Fall build new
Earth uh here take it over brother okay
you
go yeah oh I'm feeling something I'm
feeling something walls Let Them Fall
build new
Earth walls Let Them Fall build new
Earth hey yeah walls Let Them Fall build
new Earth he yeah walls Let Them Fall
Earth build new Earth
new walls Let Let Them Fall build new
Earth got to freaking let this
masculinity out man it's so suppressed
there's things that can help go let's go
hon is one of my favorite have you heard
of that band it's a Norwegian band it
it's actually German band but they they
kind of sing Norwegian Style music and
the whole the whole thing of it is just
they try to recreate the music that was
around when Humanity first kind of began
like the Stone Age and use bones and
like metal dope and the energy that
comes out of it is just insane it's this
ancient yeah
yeah the masculine and The Feminine are
just so extreme yeah like the feminine
cuz like the the freaking feminine man
it it's not like ah it's not what you
think of it nowadays the Viking women
God
damn I just think of having like a a
mother you know who teaches you your
morning routine kind of in a way
[Music]
like this
fasina oh it's happening it's going down
deeper I feel it going down in my
abdomen and if you if you have Mastery
or balance of energy of both of that
you're unstoppable it's game over I want
to learn do you know how energetic
Mastery of both those things I mean we
talked about it a bit before we started
also it's like breaking out of every
single box imaginable to identify the
thing that's deidentified you know it's
when you stop identifying as the box of
oh I I know you mean that yeah and all
that kind of stuff and then you
re-identify but from a balanced place of
being disidentified and identified and
being boxless and yet being whatever
body this is so and you don't have to
even when it
re-identify no one's there to
re-identify that that's the magic so
whatever it is it's just like whoa you
can't talk about it now right right yeah
yeah
straight
face don't
smile instant loss I'm just like this
thought came off like I'm live on it
it's
like silly there's no one there's no
live it's actually all live it's just
live always
everything much love thanks for watching
atlas's thing and thank you Alice so
freaking much thanks for coming on it's
so wonderful to meet you in person I got
to say it's an honor and and your
initiative in this new Earth I'm a
soldier I don't know what what you call
Beautiful yeah yeah I mean I don't want
to shoot anybody like like a warrior or
a lion or whatever it is or like just
being constituted as new Earth which
it's it's weird cuz it's it's almost
like it's it's it's home itself inside
and it's already there and it's just
kind of like yeah like we talked about
just gunky gunky gkess and then like ah
there we go what was there always the
child the innocent the playful the free
the Abundant let's go just die on that
sword there's nothing else to do let the
child
die let I'm serious the one the one that
the one that thinks that it can get
something from for
itself let that one die let that one die
cuz it can't it can never get what it
wants from objectification and all kinds
of [__] it will never get it from that
the separate one take our word for it
yeah he suffered for years it feels like
yeah it feels like like AA meeting
sometimes like tell me your story yeah
it is like an a oh [__] you did that let
me tell you mine oh
no you can laugh about it now but you
know and it's beautiful it's beautiful
it's not perfect but it's it's perfect
it's also perfect yes God damn
it's I love it there's comments in here
about
how this is what this is all highly
young dude does they have like they they
like audition and you make videos of
just doing this
like just like trying to summon like the
Earth's energy outwards yeah all these
[__] roads and stuff just wants
to I don't know I don't know what the
Earth wants you ask
it so um so beautiful I mean the convo
is amazing bro we went all over the
place beautifully do we started the
episode with our new company called
wholeness
episode is sponsored
byess new Earth
Hess so you'll find it's the first step
yeah you'll find our episode sponsor
wholeness of wide range of uh butt plugs
and butt accessories um which is part of
the Liber the part of The Liberation
movement of new Earth I love it yeah
they're mesh Network as well and that's
part of the wholeness concept you know
it's a big part of the technology let's
go let's go and then um we got here we
we had a nice dive into all the new
Earth stuff with uh solar Punk and all
that stuff and then we have of course
Casey's Casey's Channel you can go check
it out go subscribe go watch some
content it's fun stuff and um we'll have
some links in the bio to check that out
and um yeah there's links in the bio for
home Dow also if you want to get
homesteading and building um and and I
mean that's it I mean you got to you got
to get going cuz that thank you everyone
for tuning in we love you so much what a
[__] fun episode join us join us join
us let's new Earth new Earth new Earth
dude I just want to summon I want to
spend like an entire day like just
summoning this energy and then we'll do
like a podcast like when we're just so
freaking just to just to demonstrate
like here's what's possible I love that
idea actually yeah I love that I that's
what high
is into this we flowed into this so
beautifully and magically and
unspeakably so you know we we agree by
the way we had so many great flow
sessions during that with like musically
and stuff so dude coming like even more
like kind of like prepared into it and
then just like going into the flow of it
and just seeing where that goes and
unleashes
we got some lovely lovely comments about
yeah go Atlas and case much love much
love much love thank you so much fam we
love you thank you for tuning in
love all right bye
[Music]
bye so much fun